future sun okay we'll start with our
first one can you just give me one
second though
is it yeah just give me one second
because i haven't eaten all day
yeah and i need to order some food
before it's closed
i'll try to do something as healthy as
possible
your mom just texted me i know did she
text you and me
good news she just got she got her
second vaccination
good news i'm coming back to normal i
feel great thank you
for your emotional love for me oh
don't you love my mom i love her that's
great
oh i love her i think i literally
dressed like you did
thank you for your emotional love for me
what the [ __ ] does that mean mom
anyway go ahead video all right our
first video is
like me oh like george uh first uh
person is jack shrine
nosotros papaya nosotros congratulations
george
thank you they said you couldn't do it
mate they said you couldn't [ __ ]
and look at you now uh well done um
i was told to leave a message for your
unborn son um
something that he could look back on uh
when he was a little bit older
and see about his dad so i thought i
would
share with him so you don't have to uh
the magic of how babies are made
um so you see some
sometimes when a man loves a woman very
much he brings her eggs
and tomatoes from his garden and
sometimes
just sometimes that woman likes those
days my mom
invites him in as opposed to kicking him
out of her [ __ ] house
uh but sometimes she invites him in
and allows him to play with her stove
another stove analogy
don't want her to be turning the heat
all the way down either
but sometimes if you bring her just the
right amount of eggs
and just the right amount of home-grown
nightshade fruits
you turn the knobs of the stove just
right uh loudly chuckle at everything
she says and just the right tone
that's how babies are made um i hope
this has been helpful
uh again congratulations george they
can't take this away from you mate
love you uh keep up the good work and uh
and all the best i love you
i love you australian i hate this guy
and love this guy so much
probably right yeah he sounds south
african to me oh yeah he did the uh
good old stove analogy drawers that's a
it's a
private language yeah private length is
that that we have one more
one more how do you feel about that that
was really sweet i like that i like it
yeah
he cares deep cuts deep cuts
this guy looks like george oh my god
another george
a lot of george's are these all my
doctors george and andrew santino's baby
yeah george we were asked to uh
leave a message for your unborn baby to
listen to when he's older so
i would just like to tell him a little
bit about when
you uh when you finally got jessica um
and what a big upheaval that was and how
we're all so happy that you finally
finally got her and had to and you got
to have a baby with her
just amazing amazing really we're all so
happy
it's not jessica um
congratulations george
that that's about right that's about
right oh good
that's about right george look at those
people that look like you love you man
oh that's so good he's english no
everyone's
not from here international so you know
it's it's so strange
to um get have that you know
how lucky we are that you know there are
people
around the world that watch this